[Music]
good evening and welcome to sunday night
in america i'm trey gowdy and we're
grateful you joined us
the situation at our southern border
continues to spiral downward
it's a crisis no matter what word
politicians
use a crisis is defined as an unstable
or crucial time
i don't know what could be more crucial
than the security of our country
than knowing who is coming to this
country
and why i don't know what could be more
unstable than women and children making
a dangerous trip
fraught with all manner of peril from
cartel members to oppressive heat
i don't know what could possibly be more
unstable
than politicians preaching false hope to
desperate people
simply to score political points or
avoid having to do
what is the single hardest thing for
some politicians to do
which is admit they're wrong i'm sure
you're left to wonder
why we as a country continue to debate
these same issues
decade after decade you're left to
wonder because there is actually
consensus
among you there is consensus among most
of the people
not full agreement on every detail we
will never have that
and no not every single person is in
agreement
because there will always be those who
profit from division
and anger and disunity and then
sometimes we just disagree
but there is a broad consensus
and where there is consensus there
should be a solution
and yet nothing happens because the will
of the people never translates into
legislative action
it's almost as if the political
advantage
some elected officials perceive and
having this debate
year after year outweighs the desire of
the people
to have reasonable logical finality
and that's what i'm looking for finality
a solution
something that can last longer than one
executive order
to the next longer than one election
cycle to the next
most americans believe a sovereign
country should have border security
because a sovereign country is entitled
to know who is coming into
and going out of the country yes it's
national security
yes it makes economic sense but even
more fundamentally
a country has the right to meaningful
borders
and to have those borders respected and
honored
it's actually what makes you a country
we're not a planet of nomads
we're a planet of countries vice
president kambala harris
way too late and without a whole lot of
conviction
finally said don't come but that's
hardly provocative
to tell people not to make a dangerous
trip armed with nothing but false hope
it's not provocative to tell people to
stop trusting coyotes
or cartel members but even simply saying
don't
come vice president harris was
criticized
by that element on the far left who
really
don't believe in border security or
border integrity
so where are we if we had a secure
border
and security in our visa programs then i
think you would see
movement to the next logical stage which
is providing
legal status for those who are brought
here as children
before the age of legal accountability
you might even see movement among those
who are here now unlawfully but who have
otherwise
followed our laws and then you would see
further movement
toward a legal immigration system which
smartly balances
economic reality with our commitment to
family as the foundation of society
but we don't have border security so
there will be no movement until that
indispensable prerequisite is met
in fact not only do we not have border
security law enforcement believes
we may actually be headed in the
opposite and wrong direction
we've seen reporting on men showing up
at the southern border with criminal
histories including sexually assaulting
children we've seen an increase in
certain drugs crossing the border
just as we are finally beginning to see
some light
at the end of the opioid struggle we're
even seeing an increase in cartel
activity on our side of the border
if you want to see depravity in person
if you want to see acts of inhumanity
your good conscience cannot even
contemplate if you want to see the worst
things
you have ever seen things that will make
you question
whether there has been any moral
evolution at
all look at these cartels
they are sadistic but they are also
opportunistic they can sense the
weakness
and then they exploit it border security
is not only a country's right it is your
right
to know who and what is coming and going
from this sovereign nation
so we can keep it safe
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else